foreign
[Music]
s
hey there what's up I'm trying to think
of a way to segue to the first thing
we're talking about as opposed to the
second thing we're talking about anyway
new week
new world you might say
the world of burnout
Trump has been kicked off Twitter and
kicked from the house and now he got how
do you how do you describe Biden milk
toast geriatric
he's certainly old is like the oldest
president to sit in office
like on the day of inauguration and
isn't it also funny the way
um conservatives are complaining about
the power that internet companies have
and they were the front line against net
neutrality I want to say look the one
thing that I thought was interesting
about the whole Biden inauguration was
we usually accuse conservatives of being
nostalgic ones and definitely like
Trump's inauguration was extremely and
even military well actually very overtly
militantly nostalgic but everything
about Biden's inauguration was just
echoing 2008 super heavy like right down
to like the vanilla rhetoric you stop
out hope and change for Unity and coming
together Lady Gaga and I think it was
what JLo who are giving the performances
you know icon Garth Brooks too Garth
Brooks yeah like icons of like the mid
2000s Garth Brooks was a nice touch he
was a nice little bone to Middle America
yeah like it really had the feeling of
like one person described as like oh you
know the Obama era was this wonderful
time that people look back on with a lot
of fondness and now the adults are back
in the room after all this craziness has
kind of been passed on right yeah that's
funny because all of those performers
could have performed at Obama's well
maybe not Gaga but Obama's inauguration
it's just like maybe okay we're just
gonna erase that era now yeah basically
yeah I wonder if Lady Gaga was she
around in 2008 I think she was I think
what was it around 2000 and 8 2009 poker
poker face was the first single sometime
around there yeah yeah but she was in no
doubt before
no that was Gwen Stefani oops
right her breakthrough year was actually
2008 so maybe she could have been it but
honestly but this is what I'm saying I
am in my 30s so [ __ ] it Poker Face
it's true it is funny this is why it was
weird because it was like really
nostalgic right like everything was
about like Conjuring up this kind of
warm feeling for the Obama era making
people feel safe the adults are back in
the room uh kind of like you're saying
you know we're gonna pay attention to
science and reason and so might you say
by way of Segway Matt might you say that
we were feeling burnt out
wait can I just say one of the one other
thing about the about the inauguration
the ceremonies I thought it was uh it's
it they have such weird secularity there
in the States because you're right they
were saying like science and but then
they had all these prayers and all this
God stuff mixed in there too which is
super weird and I don't know it's funny
because I think in Canada maybe in our
constitution it's like a lot more
clearly defined but that would just
never be allowed in Canada to talk about
God in like a public ceremony like that
like that's just a total infringement on
like on like on government and public
neutrality separation I'm the one last
thing though I'm I'm very interested to
see how the aesthetic Dimension turns
out between Kamala and Biden I mean
Kamala and Joe because like Joe and
Obama had like a dope going between them
yeah they're like those pictures of them
together like
like I don't know all the and even that
little like funny little video that
Obama did that he did like a little
comedy routine in the White House and
like that was dope and then we had four
years of like a man shouting over a
helicopter into the camera at our faces
and now we have Joe and Kamala and we're
gonna have to see I I can't imagine them
having the same sort of broey dynamic
that obtained between Biden and Obama
anyway yeah you can cut that out sorry
um thank you for putting up with our
pre-episode banter this is kind of the
only time in the week that we talk
anyway so we had to we had to cover the
media landscape and speaking of media
landscape because we gotta do this whole
Segway thing today uh the topic was
actually chosen by you a month ago
um alethea Caitlyn and all the other
people who liked their suggestion wanted
us to do an episode on biancho Han's
burnout society which we all read
um a little bit of background
I had to look most of this up because
well this was the second book that I
read of his but he's a German theorist
maybe a public intellectual I'm not sure
um if any German recluse if any Germans
know this guy uh you can comment and let
us know if he shows up on TV or anything
he doesn't like his picture taken I I
really fun fact I think he's a Swiss
German isn't he
yeah he's a Swiss German Korean born
well he got a degree in Korea and then
moved to Basel
yeah he was studying uh Metallurgy in in
before he moved to Germany and took up
philosophy
I was talking to some people on a stream
or or maybe in the Discord and they said
that he was overrated but I don't know
how he can be overrated because I never
really heard of him until a few months
ago even though he has like 16 books out
same
yeah
it's only our patrons who brought them
to my attention he does I don't think
that like he's showed up at any on any
of the syllabi of the kinds of
philosophy classes I've taken maybe more
in cultural studies and stuff like that
but right right well his main thing is
uh the transparency thesis of
neoliberalism which is uh sort of
paradoxical because he doesn't like
showing up on camera and he doesn't like
any private details about his life being
known so he's opposite of public
intellectual in terms of that but his
writing style and most of his books
which are often under 100 Pages seem to
be written for a popular audience not an
academic audience
but it does help to have a bit of
background in the stuff he's talking
about
sure anyway we will conduct this uh
episode as if you haven't read it so
that even if you haven't read it you can
get something out of uh what he talks
about it only I read it in a sitting
it's only short what less than or 60
Pages or something like that so yeah
it's like yeah it's really short it took
him no time to read if you like it it
might be worth a look burnout
burnout uh so yeah the burnout I mean
this kind of fits with our earlier
discussion of
of from Trump to Biden the burnout is
basically a result of course we live in
a society basically a result of living
in a society and if you know anything
about the Foucault disciplinary Society
model
uh de Liz interestingly said that we
moved from a disciplinary Society to a
control Society Foucault himself said we
moved from a disciplinary Society to a
biopolitical society and bianchohan here
is throwing his hat in the ring to say
we move from a disciplinary Society to
an achievement society and the flip side
of the achievement there is burnout
yeah or uh it's also translated as as
tiredness Society sometimes the the
German word I don't know our German
patrons can correct me if it's the the
mutikites gazelle shaft does the is the
tiredness Society
kind of muric means I'm like hey yeah
I'm tired sounds like what it is I like
the translation are they uh the uh
pronunciation there Eric yeah I've been
practicing I've just been saying it over
and over and again in preparing for this
moment all right guys see you later I
was gonna say what it reminded me of
when I was looking into this and again I
know very little about this so this is
inferring a lot but was actually a lot
of Weber's arguments about the
Protestant work ethic and the kind of
centrality of work uh that many
proto-capitalist societies
um placed uh upon labor right uh and
it's got a moral value and you know one
of the things that Weber constantly
pointed out was exactly this idea that
people now tend to look at their time
not as something what that should be
used to develop themselves spiritually
or aesthetically but it's time that
should be allocated to labor because you
live in a competitive society and the
degree to which you're able to succeed
in that demonstrates your worth or your
value to a certain extent and he points
out that this is going to create a
profound sense of alienation and
dissatisfaction since all lot of people
in these societies aren't able to
actually just sit there and enjoy
leisure right right and that's what this
is the difference between like a a
factory job type situation where you
kind of go to work and leave your work
at work
the the entrepreneurial or performative
or achievement Society
means that you have to do work at home
now you have to like as academics I'm
sure you guys
get this is like if you're not
publishing there's someone else who's
publishing there's someone else who's
trying to get that that last spot at the
University so even your leisure has to
be a form of self-production into you
know commodification a self
commodification for the purposes of
trying to have a retirement eventually
yeah yeah for sure actually I was
thinking about reading a quote here from
the book I've got open here that is
maybe a nice exemplification of the
shift from the disciplinary Society to
the
um uh what was the achievement Society
so he says uh disciplinary Society is a
society of negativity it is defined by
the negativity of prohibition the
negative model verb that governs it is
may not by the same token the negativity
of compul of compulsion adheres to
should
achievement Society more and more is in
the process of discarding negativity
increasing deregulation is abolishing it
unlimited can is the positive model verb
of achievement Society it's plural form
the affirmation yes we can epitomizes
achievement society's positive
orientation prohibition
Commandments and the law are replaced by
projects initiatives and motivation
disciplinary Society is still governed
by no negativity produces Mad Men and
criminals in contrast achievement
Society creates depressives and losers
all right so we're gonna have to break
that down why don't you take a first
crack at it Eric well the first thing
about burnout society and this is I'm
just taking this from examples he gave
is he's you know like go on to a go on
to the subway at rush hour and you'll
you'll see that we're living in a
burnout Society in in a big way you'll
see people passed out on the subway
sleeping in like impossible positions I
I always remember sitting on the going
like even if I'm going to school at some
weird hour like around in the evening
I'll see people just sleeping and
Preposterous positions and it's because
everyone's burnt out you'll even look at
the news and you see things like nurses
burning out doctors burning out students
burning out right like it's you get like
four hours of sleep a day
and you work work work work work
and it's it's a sort of social pattern
that's been developing for quite some
time he stretches this argument back
into history a little bit I mean the
guy's like what 60 years old he's seen
quite a bit
so the burnout Society is is the society
we're in it's the it's the flip side of
the achievement society and the can-do
attitude it's it's not the negativity
it's in excess of positivity it's the
excess of that can-do attitude
and it it it builds up in our in our
ability to keep going and keep doing it
and when we fail when we collapse when
we can't do it anymore we take that to
be a failure on our part and we don't
question the society we live in and
really what he's doing is he's giving us
the tools to to do that and to
conceptualize it by saying we live in a
burnout Society this is actually you're
not alone here if you're if you feel
depressed or if you feel even ADHD seems
like the opposite of depression it's a
kind of uh it's a kind as a
hyperactivity but it's still the result
of the same sort of
process yeah I actually can remember
distinctly where I first felt like an
entrepreneur of the self as he puts it
uh they're never in like an uncritical
are kind of uh embracing way uh that's
sometimes described in the book it was
actually I went to a career counselor of
all things and I basically sat there
with this career counselor I was like
blah blah like what should I do I have
one year left in my PhD like I published
these papers like what's going on and
she's like wow like you've done your job
but isn't there other things you could
do like why don't you create a website
why don't you get on Twitter I recommend
that if you do get on Twitter you try to
tweet at least 20 times a day during
these time periods because that'll
maximize your viewership maybe create
something like a YouTube channel which
will get you exposure on this and what
ended up happening when I came away from
this conversation is I sat there
thinking myself like well I'm pretty
lazy just doing
what they expect me to do based on this
list of criteria right because there's
so much more I could be doing uh that
isn't explicitly laid out but is now
increasingly implicitly expected of you
uh if you want to be able to compete and
what really struck me was also again how
personalized a lot of this was because
they'd say well things on Twitter should
be more
personal and affected we should talk
about what your internal life your
feelings about things what's going on so
you turn yourself into a kind of
marketing tool right a personality if
you were and I found that all extremely
odd right because it really testified to
what pills was talking about right how
we don't even live in an academic
Factory anymore you know my job is
essentially a 24-hour job and if I'm not
using all that time effectively well
then I should feel to a certain extent
guilty about it because there are other
things I could be doing yeah that's
exactly what he's describing so I
thought just to get everyone on the same
page I'll just read the desk jacket
because I think it actually does a good
job
which says our competitive
service-oriented societies are taking a
toll on the late modern individual
rather than improving life multitasking
user-friendly technology and the culture
of convenience are producing disorders
that range from depression depression to
attention deficit disorder to borderline
personality disorder bianchohan
interprets the spreading malaise as an
inability to manage negative experiences
in an age characterized by excessive
positivity and the universal
availability of people and goods so
stress and exhaustion are a result
obviously as we said but it's
interesting the way he uses
the terms positive and negative here
it's not it's not like positive means
happy and negative means unhappy it's
rather uh what kind of information you
receive and like a positive feedback
loop or a negative feedback loop or in
Foucault's disciplinary Society you're
told
no in terms of the space that you're
allowed to inhabit if you cross the
boundary into the space that you're not
allowed to be in that's when you're
punished uh if you act crazy then you're
put into the Asylum sort of thing and in
a positive his version of positivity
means that you can't filter information
or negative information out anymore
uh because you have to say yes to
everything you have to react to
everything and that's kind of where
what's Matt what Matt's talking about in
terms of Twitter comes in here you have
to have an opinion on everything you're
asked for your opinion at all times a
day
and uh you have to have an opinion to
almost be the commodity the presence
commodity that you are and I kind of
find it funny that we're doing a podcast
and uh YouTube because doing doing
exactly what you have to do because
being an academic is not good enough
anymore
yeah I should say there's also a weird
an interesting critique of
performativity in his work right this
kind of Pastiche like self-performance
that we engage in to transform our
personalities and our internal life into
Social Capital uh but it's really very
different than the kind of
performativity that you see somebody
like Judith Butler arguing for where uh
performativity can be kind of
self-conscious attempt to play with your
personality uh or play with your
identity to develop in in certain
aesthetically intriguing ways uh this is
a kind of performativity that's
relentlessly pushed upon you uh by the
society that you live in and oftentimes
it's not necessarily something you even
want to engage in but it's something
that you feel compelled to do like
you're playing out the script well it's
interesting because it it reminds me
like the the pressure that we feel uh
like the social pressure you know and
this transition from uh you know the
disciplinary Society to the achievement
Society it kind of reminds me of that
transition that Zizek sometimes talks
about in psychoanalysis where you know
before um talked about how like
psychoanalysts and Freud's time right
would talk about how like patients like
analogens their problem would often be a
problem of of not of of an of having too
much desire that they that they can't
suppress like they're supposed to in
society right so they feel ashamed for
having too much desire yeah because the
social pressure is to push it in but now
it's like the opposite where people
analyzens are are finding that they're
anxious and ashamed of not having enough
desire
so they feel the social pressure to have
desire to enjoy enjoy more things yes
you know have more weird like try out
new sexual experiments do more things
and and and like you know uh fulfill all
your desires but then people will feel
shame if they're like well I don't
really have these desires and like these
messages that I'm supposed to be
enjoying all these things yeah I don't
really want to so maybe there's
something wrong with me get a hobby
start a business on the side make sure
you're investing your money you have to
you have to constantly be saying yes to
things that you didn't even know you had
to say yes for exactly you're so you're
you're you're it's like you're supposed
to be unsatisfied with all these things
uh yeah you're supposed to have more
desire for things now like it gets
hegelian in a way to he says Hegel is
one of the most important philosophers
from him so you also take the negative
positive thing in in um
in a hegelian fashion as well so in the
in the the old way the old Society right
is a is characterized by a dialectic of
negativity and just to give an example I
feel like 9 11 might have been like the
culmination of this right the the idea
of setting up an other who is foreign
who is outside you who is elsewhere
someone who's an Invader or even I mean
you can just keep switching frames an
immunological perspective right a virus
is an other it's something outside of
you that we have to defend against and
the negativity is because that thing
wants to enter you whatever you may be
your body your community your Society
whatever it may be and negate you right
and then in order to assert yourself
against this sort of violence of the
other you have to assert your being
right and you have to negate the
negation that's a famous phrase from
Hegel [ __ ] creating the negation
whereas the problem we're faced with
today which which I think
is different like 911 right set up an
other whereas today what we're
experiencing is this excess of
positivity not of negativity and
otherness but of positivity and sameness
and so that struggle almost goes inside
of us and this was all a lot more true
than like about three weeks ago than it
is now yeah because we're in the midst
of a pandemic in this immunological view
maybe we're not done with it I don't
know but but in any case
the the positivity is a is the positive
Society this achievement Society is is a
war with yourself basically like why
can't I do this why am I so tired why
don't I give a [ __ ] about anything and
you feel bad about it and you don't
question Society you think it's your
failure your lack of positivity in a
sense is your own demon now and you're
and and the struggle goes inside and he
gives a great example of the Master
Slave dialectic right like everyone
today is their own master and slave at
the same time the struggle is the
struggle is real and it's inside you
and if you feel like being lazy and
doing nothing and there's a voice in
your head saying get up and go get up
and do this and it's making you anxious
or neurotic or depressed that's what
he's talking about we're living in this
burnout society which is just the flip
side of the coin of the achievement
Society is that the losers and the
failures are the ones who can't live up
to the expectations that are put on them
by
Society at large I'll throw a different
way right like um there was an
interesting moment in the biography by
Stephen Schwartzman uh who is a the CEO
of several major companies and a
multi-billionaire and a sportsman in the
book uh talks about a discussion he had
with his dad who owned a small drugstore
uh and his dad had a comfortable middle
class life and Schwartzman goes to him
and basically is like why don't you
actually Market this more effectively
because we can take your little
drugstore and make it huge and the dad
responded by saying why would I want to
do that it'll be more work for me I'm
happy I have two cars I have a nice
house I sent my kids to college and
that's enough uh at schwartzman's take
away from this it wasn't actually that
his dad was right he actually says his
dad lacked entrepreneurial Drive which
is why he never became as successful as
his son right and it's really intriguing
because his dad was by all accounts even
his own account happy right he was
contented with who he was and what he
achieved and I'm not saying this to kind
of argue for some kind of puritanical
antihedonism or something right but I
think it really does demonstrate how
this yearning for more and to always try
to commodify yourself and to modify
anything else around you can become
temperamentally actuated across the
entirety of our society in some really
interesting and malicious ways right I
remember there was a study done by
um in Shapiro who's a democratic
theorist uh at Yale and he was looking
at why it is that people want more money
uh even when they don't get any kind of
concrete benefit from it right and he
said if you look at like ancient
doctrines about marginal utility not
ancient doctrines like uh modernist
doctrines about marginal utility every
dollar that you should receive on top of
a dollar that you have should become
less and less valuable right if I have a
million dollars having 10 million
dollars should be less meaningful than
that if I have 10 million dollars having
100 million dollars should be less
meaningful and so on and so forth but
that's not the way these people tend to
approach it and Shapiro's conclusion is
that the interesting thing is that
people tend to approach money and other
forms of social capital and gain not
according to doctrines of marginal
utility but rather the way addicts treat
drugs right uh where if your first hit
is pretty good but after that you need a
bigger and bigger hit each time in order
to get the same rush and if that doesn't
seem to embody this is the ethos of this
kind of achievement Society I don't know
what does right it really is almost this
kind of drug stimulating you to go
further and further if you can and never
to feel satiated uh with what's
achievable at any given moment yeah or
another another good like metaphor for
the shift along those lines too is
taking taking drugs for headaches for
instance right like a headache in the
old Society the headache is something
outside you and you take a drug to uh
cure the headache and then in the new
Society the drug is now causing the
headache it's you're becoming dependent
on it if you don't have it you you get
headaches basically the drug causes it
it's it's almost like the pharmacon
argument that there it out where the the
Cure sort of shifts into becoming the
poison but it's internal and it's a
dependency rather than something
external you have to build walls or
defend against you know Trump is like
the last gasp of the disciplinary
Society in this sort of way
right well I don't know if this was in
the book you can tell me because I have
it in my reading notes and I'm not sure
if I if it was my own words or his but
uh his thesis is that repression is like
the energy stored in a spring so you
push it down and that kind of builds up
energy to kind of resist and he he's
dealing it with it in the psychoanalytic
sense that the um
the disciplinary Society produces
hysterics because you know you have to
follow your social role you're not
allowed to break your social role but
when you have no social roles defined
what you have is infinite freedom and
infinite freedom is bad for I mean it's
not bad necessarily it's what causes a
depressive State because that's like the
Str the spring now has been stretched
out so that there's no more springiness
in it so the the exhaustion is the
spring being stretched out because you
have nothing no limit to push against
because the limit is just be more
yourself be more actualized express your
desires more freely so when you have
nothing to push against then it becomes
well what the hell do I do I can wake up
with an Infinity of opportunity
so I want to speak to that quickly like
so I think it's this is a it's a good
I'm glad you brought that up because I
think it's sort of the point where I was
not sure if I agreed with uh the author
because I felt like you know is it
really the case that the problem like I
think the the distinction between
positivity and negativity and like that
that part makes sense but like is it
really
the is it really the case that there's
nothing to live up to like isn't it
actually the case that there are social
roles that like that the culture make up
that you know we're supposed to be this
hyper productive successful like finding
and there's like images of it right on
social media that people to various
extents wish that they could be that
thing so I feel like there is still a
pressure to fit into a social role and
like a Prohibition like there is still a
kind of pressure to be like well you
can't just be this ordinary person like
so there's a shame with being this like
ordinary person so I guess I wasn't
convinced that this was like you know to
to hearken back to the last podcast we
have to think about this more radically
I was like thinking well I'm not sure if
this is actually as radically different
from the Freudian repression it's just a
different kind because the messages and
the social roles are instilled with this
positivity and this like you know
fulfilling your desire I don't know well
there's there's something to live up to
the thing that's different there is that
one is saying you can't do something or
even you shouldn't do something like a
moral imperative
for a woman a hundred years ago it's you
can't go to university but now the
difference is you should go to
university so one is drawing a negative
a restriction whereas the should is you
should go to university plus you should
start your own business plus you should
have hobbies on the side plus you should
be the mother in everything that you
were before so it's a it's demanding
that you use your freedom rather than
saying you can't do anything and that
would be the next isn't that isn't that
a Prohibition on being just like
ordinary being satisfied with like your
with your prescribed role like isn't
that saying like you know you're I mean
you could frame it that way I guess but
there's no actual restriction there
there's no like
one of the examples he gives is is he
says in in Germany right like people are
envious of how well Koreans do on these
tests
and people want to live up to that
that's the that's the sort of
achievement standard right but he says
what what people don't realize is how
many Koreans are overwhelmed by this and
end up committing suicide for instance
as a result of this
this drive to achieve right like we we
see it all the times like International
students who are studying to become
doctors or lawyers or engineers and
they're just working around the clock
they sleep in the library and they bring
their toothbrush and we think wow that's
like that's a model of discipline and
and achievement that I want to like why
can't I be that but the truth is like
that is causing a whole load of like
whatever what would you call it like
psychosocial problems are emerging
because of that sort of model of
achievement right so you have this sort
of strange situation where where say
Asian students are achieving so much but
then we hide the fact that it's taking
this psychological toll and not only on
their minds but I mean he he describes
the way Korea
modernized so quickly right it went from
a sort of place-based community-based
kind of agrarian society and it just
became hyper modernized like very
quickly and that created So Korea is
probably one of the like exemplars of
this and I maybe we can think about like
you at the U.S is kind of lagging behind
this sort of development as well like
they're sort of maybe in the
transitional period still whereas a lot
of Asian societies have reached it
Germany is certainly there as well
they're doing a lot better than other
European nations on these standards as
well but but it's creating these these
issues and he says that the psychosocial
landscape or topology is defined Now by
these
these neurological diseases that are
emerging because of this achievement
this imperative to achieve so you're
getting again things like add depression
whatever obsessive-compulsive disorder
and borderline personality disorders and
things like that so there is the
standard and it's good
but we're ignoring the toll that it's
taking and who like is it sustainable is
it something we need I mean is it
something we want to just go back to
when the pandemic is over maybe not
yeah because I don't get the sense that
this is kind of a conservative argument
for a return to forms of traditionalism
and set identitarian roles uh that were
better than what we see now and I kind
of agree with Victor here that I don't
think there's anything wrong with the
kind of Freedom that he's talking about
right or that's available at this point
uh it's just that the kind of burdens uh
that are associated with that right and
the sense that whatever you're doing
isn't good enough uh and I think you can
see the kind of cultural pushback
against this and a lot of the forms of
Art and even pop culture uh that became
popular in the late 2000s through the
mid uh 2010s think about somebody like
Seth Rogen and every movie in that vein
right what you really see with Seth
Rogen and Jonah Hill uh and all these
kind of films uh is the slacker or the
stoner becoming almost kind of uh
counterintuitively a hero or
revolutionary against the system right
because he or she is somebody who
refuses to participate in the
achievement Society right they want to
just earn enough money to be able to sit
at home play video games hang out with
their friends form a little Community
Based on smoking weed and have a good
time that way right and this isn't to
say that there's some kind of great
depths to these movies but I do think
that they reflect an enemy on the part
certainly of American society about how
much pressure
is allocated to our lives alongside the
new kinds of Freedom that are also
available
well in a way those those symbolic
resolutions where we say like I reject
that
and I'm just going to live my sort of
Stoner burnout lifestyle in pieces is
sort of the opposite of what he's
describing
because you have you have a society that
prescribes Freedom as the goal right we
need to be free and this is the source
of this excess of positivity and when we
internalize it and then we can't live up
to it what we do is we form compulsions
and these compulsions well he calls it
compulsive freedom and in a way like
compulsion is a constraint right it's
something you you're compelled to do and
so in this way freedom and constraint
come to be the same thing there's no
difference there is no real Freedom he
says but that's actually that's where I
kind of disagreed with him was like that
it's not so like that's that was kind of
my point before that like yeah you can
say that the thing we're trying to live
up to is freedom but I think that that's
not really true because as I said
spontaneously these cultural figures
show up that people are trying to live
up to it's not just like Freedom it's
not like oh I just want to be free you
have like you know the the Instagram
spectacle of people that you're looking
at having a great time and you want to
live up to those like it's more
determined than just freedom but like
maybe the ideology of Freedom produced
the hyper-real environment that we're in
in the technological environment that
we're in right now but I don't think
that in our mind it's like people are
like we have to be free it's like
they're they're seeing specific things
and like cultural you know um like like
um different cultural symbology and like
Lifestyles that are specific that they
want to live up to and then they feel
shame and burnout because they're like
not doing enough to get to those various
ideals right well it certainly is it's
certainly not freedom in the hegelian
sense of being self-determined it's
freedom to be who you are deep inside or
whatever or the freedom to consume As
You Wish like the compulsion to enjoy so
it's not the freedom to actually be who
you are
yeah like the idea isn't that there's
one section of society the wealthy that
are free and they're exploiting another
section of the society who are fettered
and chained to wage slavery like that's
the old Marxist View and he's saying
this doesn't do this doesn't cut it
anymore because we're not we're not uh
enslaved section of the population to a
bourgeoisie that's not the case anymore
we Auto exploit we exploit ourselves we
voluntarily give up our own freedom in
in a certain way right every time you
touch your phone every time you go on
Facebook every time you allow big data
to extract information from yourself
you're giving up a sort of
that that that maybe classical liberal
freedom of the private sphere and the
idea of interiority and the idea that
that's my space and nobody else's and
nobody has a right to see what I'm doing
with my own personal freedom like that's
just not that's no longer a reality the
idea that we're protecting our freedom
from Facebook and Twitter is just absurd
now because we live in this big data
society and we voluntarily subject
ourselves to it like it's a new version
of the question that de los and gutari
asked in anti-edipus where they said why
do we desire our own enslavement like it
seems like we just don't even want to be
free and what he's saying is freedom is
a standard that we just can't live up to
and we internalize that failure and we
enslave ourselves because that's much
more efficient right the old model of
capitalism is one section of society
exploiting another that which is very
inefficient and you can still have
solidarity with the exploited but in
this new Society you can't have
solidarity with the exploited because
again we are the Masters and the slaves
at the same time we voluntarily exploit
ourselves and whether we know we're
doing that or not is inconsequential
because it's a social pattern that he's
talking he's not talking about
individual psychology and what we know
or don't know happy Friday folks
enjoy your weekend one thing that I want
to say just to kind of finish my point
right is that you know the kind of
inverse image from what you see with the
slacker revolutionary that you saw in
some films that were released around the
time of this book it was also the
Resurgence of mythological figures uh in
pop Cinema people like superheroes who
are simultaneously Geniuses extremely
wealthy and rip shape always have
attractive women and so on and so forth
right and I think these two grinding
areas that you can see Express the real
tension in our culture that he's talking
about in this book right on the one hand
and some people see being a burnout as a
revolution as a revolutionary act
precisely because they choose not to
self-enslave at least in the kind of way
that's talked about in this book but of
course then they're just becoming the
slaves to their own habits right or to
various forms of substance abuse uh or
you know they buy into this image of the
person who should have it all right uh
who can't just be even good at one thing
but has to be a complete human being
capable of expressing every iteration of
themselves through consumption right and
the question that I have drawing upon
like what Eric was saying is whether or
not that this is a social problem or
whether it's actually a testament to
some deeper distaste for Freedom that
you see genuine freedom self-determining
freedom uh in human psychology because
there are some people who have been
willing to flirt with that idea a good
example would be Eric Fromm right in his
book the same Society from says the
problem wasn't just Nazi Society right
the problem was that most people don't
want to be free self-determiners right
uh because it creates this endemic sense
of Chaos in their view of reality and
consequently they'll even be willing to
accept unfreedom uh if that provides
them with a sense of ordinatliness and
regularity in the world yeah that's
interesting because he says he says
something along these lines too he says
you know like it's almost like we never
wanted to be free in the first place
like in a way we invented God in order
that we cannot be free because we have
to do what
will atone for our guilt that's that's
the idea we have we have a debt to God
we have guilt and really the new version
of that now is the is national debt
right all the politicians always talk
about how they my hands are tied right
like this is what Biden is probably
going to start he's going to start
sending these signals out in the next
couple weeks and when the honeymoon is
over and we're all like [ __ ] this idiot
is he's gonna be saying I well that I
can't do because of the budget you know
I got a the deficit we're in a deficit
my hands are tied and it's just the new
version of of enslavement and so he does
kind of I cheated and looked at another
book The the psychopolitics book The the
slightly newer one but I think I think
the argument is still in Burnout society
as well as we well yeah we never desired
to be free in the first place we just
find a new form of of servitude to jump
into so Matt yeah like earlier you said
you know I don't think this is an
argument for going back to something and
you're right I don't think it is and I
think mostly like uh tool Hawk is uh who
is it what is it Han is his last name um
Aleister McIntyre or even Max Weber is
saying yeah once upon a time things were
so much better everybody had their role
come now Max Weber never said that no
the book the book is definitely the book
is definitely descriptive like I don't
think I don't necessarily think it's
prescriptive although there's there's
definitely like a lot of charge
statements that make it obvious that he
thinks that some of these things are bad
but I do think this is like an
interesting example of of like critical
theory and like you know kind of
horseshoe Theory where I think like
someone like Patrick dinean could read
this book and be like yes I love this
like exactly yeah like you know did you
make this into a reaction you're right I
did get that Frankfurt School Vibe too
of like there's nothing we can do
there's the crushing weight of the
culture industry over our heads and then
that's just the way it is so [ __ ] you
I'm not going to tell you what to do
next didn't you would be like well yeah
that's why we need like prescribed
gender roles with a thick culture that
like tells us what our social role is
supposed to be because like that's going
to make us happier yeah he's not
prescriptive in that way no no
definitely not uh who and his hun is not
sorry there's one there's one thing that
we're missing here in our uh recap of
the text and that's the role of the
other because you're right that there's
this new
instated tyranny but now it's very much
self-instated for him and he says the
cause for that is that now there is no
other the entrepreneur
has no other it has no boss it has no
employees it's self-starting because the
entrepreneur has no negativity it
doesn't have those bounds so the other
is only reliant on him him or herself
and then that's the cause of depression
is that not not that the the spring is
being pushed down it's that the spring
is spread out too far I guess because
you don't have a you don't have others
to actually relate to and you could
reinstate this into Market relations and
say you know every every other person
who's doing anything remotely similar to
you is now competition there's no sense
of an emancipatory politic through a
class or through organized organized
politics because everybody has to you
know succeed on their own terms not
relative to somebody else I mean
relative wait I said that wrong relative
to other people that are competition but
there is no real other that actually
actually enters your experience
yeah I mean it kind of reminded me just
go back to Victor's Point uh of that
g-jack anecdote right uh that the worst
form of exploitation that can come is
self-exploitation uh and this propensity
to internalize the Norms of ideological
domination right it's not when your dad
tells you you have to go to Grandma and
and you have no choice it's when your
dad tells you it's your choice whether
you want to go but you do know that your
grandmother loves you so you should want
to go that's where the real problem lies
right and true you can map that
perfectly on to what like people think
now it's like you know it's not that you
have to go on Twitter but like a lot of
people are on Twitter and like they're
having they're having a good time I mean
I argued this all to you before and I
know that because I was just like look
gotta be competitive we got to do this
and that's exactly how I felt when I was
at this meeting right where I was like I
really don't necessarily want to do all
these things I feel like I'm doing it
off already but then you know that
internalized voice in your mind you know
postmodern super ego I guess is like
well don't you want to be competitive
don't you want to do everything you can
to be successful don't you want to
achieve right so why aren't you doing in
these things yeah
and it's combined with an expressivist
ethic right because it's like you can go
online you can express your personality
right don't you want to share yourself
with the world right yeah exactly maybe
we should talk about the Bartleby part
of this book though toward the end I
don't know if you want to get to that
yet or not pills
the Bartleby case chapter one one thing
before we get there um I think the I
wrote specifically in my notes while
writing this in caps this needs more
lacan because of exactly what you're
saying I thought that too because of
exactly what you're saying that is the
imposition of the other demanding you to
succeed so that is exactly in the same
sense of tyranny but that's not what
bungal-chan saying because his he's he's
saying that there's a reaction to this
which is depressive basically
not that you are forcing yourself to try
hard and then you quit it's that you
just try hard until there's no energy
left in you and that's why you're
depressed because depression is not
self-hatred depression is is exhaustion
isn't it a crisis of Desire that like
you stop Desiring yeah because you've
desired too much it's not because you're
Desiring the wrong things because that
would be a different uh psychological
state that would be lack it's lack of
Desire I think
that would be the hysteric though the
hysteric is like self-punishing whereas
the depressed or the just if you're in
depression you don't desire because
you've desired too much not because
you're punishing yourself so I think
that's a key distinction to be made that
I would actually probably side with
Lacon on this
yeah same that was my feeling as well
earlier like I think it's I agree that
there is a role for the other in a way
and and you can understand that with
yeah and we've been we've been endorsing
this book pretty hard but I think we
were talking right before we started uh
recording here and all of us had
problems with it problems with the
writing style but I think why don't we
get to our critique after we talk about
the Bartleby case
and the Bartleby case this should be I
think a YouTube video because it was
written on by
it was written on by Foucault and now
it's written
always wearing that I prefer not to
shirts and the Obey shirts and a gambin
to a gambin Liz the Bartleby
yeah he kind of claims that they all
read they all read the Bartleby story
wrong because they read it from either
like a disciplinary Society point of
view or an immunological perspective or
basically a perspective where the other
or negativity plays a big role and they
look at I prefer not to as a refusal
right like that's oh that's the
progressive Act of refusal I mean I'm
I'm I'm not going to consent I'm not
going to I'm going to refuse and he says
that's that's a silly way to read it
because like obviously uh spoiler alert
at the end of the story Bartleby like
refuses everything and just stands in a
courtyard until he dies he refuses like
life itself and just like Embraces death
and he says like their readings don't
really like before we jive with that
ending there but yeah I'm I'm jumping
way ahead before we go further why don't
we explain what the Bartleby case is so
it's a is it a short story or a part of
a it's a Melville short story about Wall
Street and working being uh the guy's
like a copy a copyist or it's called a
scrivener so all he does is yeah they
didn't have photocopy machines you just
have one person uh copy documents out by
hand to make duplicates and the story is
told not From bartleby's perspective but
from his like middle manager type boss
who he gets asked to do or Bartleby gets
asked to do things in the office and
eventually he's just like I prefer not
to and he won't do anything that he's
told and the narrator sort of resents
him for this because he's not being a a
proper employee like everybody else is
yeah at the end Bartleby just kind of
stands in a courtyard
and there's like a little bit of nature
like maybe like a little shock of grass
but he's like in New York and like the
Wall Street District or whatever and he
kind of just like he gets to the point
where he just dies like he stops he
refuses to like feed himself he refuses
to perform like basic biological
functions and he just he just kind of
dies but some of these I guess I guess
the point is that some of some of the
other readings take this up as like a
revolutionary Act shirt
yeah it's it's a revolutionary act as
the polar opposite of when he wears the
shirt that says obey or when you put on
the glasses and the advertisement just
says you're free to do as we tell you or
whatever isn't it also interesting that
that uh chulhan does not uh reference
zizek's reading of the Bartle BK like of
the Bartleby case in the book it doesn't
reference like any Lacon or Jack it
seems like he's not really into that no
he's all up in agambin and Kafka and
things like that like I I wouldn't say
he's unaware of those things but he
chooses not to I think I agree with uh
Eric's reading here uh of the Bartleby
story though I I haven't read it right
but uh tip from my reading of like Moby
Dick right the kind of self denial uh
Southern social denial that you see
people like Ahab engage in isn't usually
treated very positively by Melville
right like am starts by basically
starting to dissociate from his company
then he starts from about Associated
from the crew and then finally in the
kind of Final Act he ends up throwing
away his pipe which was like a menial
pleasure and just decides all I'm going
to commit to is hunting this whale and
that's going to be my obsession I deny
everything else in life except for the
singular passion right and obviously
this is treated as a kind of insane act
and based upon the reading the kind of
sense I got from bardubby was exactly
like Eric's it almost reminded me of Kim
who's left around sure right uh who at
the end is seen as almost this kind of
proto-revolutionary figure even though
he's a nihilist who overtly says I don't
really believe in anything I don't
really do anything for any concrete
reasons I just am and in some senses the
ultimate act uh for me would be to not
be which is eventually what's going to
end up happening right now that's the
big difference between Ahab and Bartleby
though is that Ahab was consumed by
Passion for something whereas Bartleby
just preferred not to do anything
including eating yeah at the end so he
starves to death
it's true right
the same kind of gesture right of just
gradually withdrawing from the world and
throwing away as many of your Social
ties and social obligations as you can
to the point where you become less and
less of a person right
yeah so what is what is like chulhan's
main point with the Bartle be like how
does he want to read it I don't know if
I I can't remember right now so I'm
asking you guys I think uh you gotta
contrast it with a gambin's reading
that's that's what he's doing so I think
the quote here kind of sums it up
um and and there's another thing we
didn't mention is that is that in in
this burnout Society the eye goes to
being a project yourself is a project
you are a project that you work on right
and you have to build yourself into a
successful human being uh but he says
Bartleby does not fail in the project of
being an eye monotonous copying leaves
no free space in which private
initiative would prove necessary or even
possible what makes Bartleby sick is not
excessive positivity or possibility he's
not burdened by the late modern
imperative of letting his self flourish
maybe a little shot at Nussbaum there
the activity of copying in particular
does not admit initiative Bartleby who
still lives in the Society of
conventions and institutions does not
know the wearing out of the ego that
leads to the depressive eye tiredness
but the problem is a gambin l elevates
Bartleby to a metaphysical position of
the highest potency
Han says and agaman says this is the
philosophical constellation to which
Bartleby the scrivener belongs as a
scribe who has stopped writing Bartleby
is the extreme figure of the nothing
from which all creation derives and at
the same time he constitutes the most
implacable Vindication of this nothing
is pure absolute potentiality the
scrivener has become The Writing Tablet
he is now nothing other than his white
sheet so he calls this an Anto
theological reading of the bardobi story
and he disagrees with this reading
because and he doesn't pay attention to
those pathological elements that he
wants to talk about depression anxiety
add and and and the refusal to almost
the refusal to live not just the refusal
to participate in a corrupt Society or
in onto theological kind of
constellation yeah and I think you could
also just criticize this from a pure
hegelian point of view right I mean
what's the point of being pure
potentiality with having a completely
white candidate upon which to write if
you so neuted yourself uh that you have
absolutely nothing that you want to say
and in fact where you decide that not
saying anything uh is in and of itself
an act of defiance in some way shape or
form yeah bartlebees dazine is a
negative being unto death which
contradicts agambin's interpretation and
I'm not gonna lie I I haven't liked the
gambling for a long time in part because
I feel that he does have this tendency
to like to appeal to exactly this kind
of Auto theological tropes and the more
radical seemingly sound the more he
finds them appealing he's always trying
to offer an even more radical rating
yeah exactly right well that's it he
falls right into that Paradigm that I
find so frustrating right it's like no
we need to push past any kind of
positivity towards pure negativity
because pure negativity is paradoxically
the most positive thing we can have
because it's absolute potentiality and
it's just like shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up I'm just so tired of
that yeah I can't this was a month ago
but can you remind me because that that
sounds it doesn't sound like Bartleby
suffering from an excess of positivity
it sounds like he begins and ends as
nothing so I don't I can't remember
where that fits into the argument
yeah that's what he says um he says a uh
Bartleby does not suffer from excess
possibility or positive so is Bartle be
more honest than the rest of us not
realists
I mean I
I think that's the point is that
bartleby's refusal
to do what he is able to do to that like
his refusal to follow the you can do
this he refuses to be a project
and the problem is the onto theological
readings make this big deal out of the
refusal but for for Han the refusal is
predicated on the refusal of the being
able
so it's not it's not like a uh I don't
think it's supposed to be a story of of
Hope where we can right just we can just
withdraw our consent from from something
we we dislike about Society it's it's
it's again about internalizing
the limits of the can do by running up
against our own limits
to you know be able to do something to
to to actualize our potential like we
have unlimited potential we're told the
sky's the limit but
I think Bartleby is supposed to be a
sort of I mean again Bartleby seems to
be before the
burnout Society might have developed
it's a it's an old story but he's he's
arguing against these other readings of
it one more great uh little bit we can
touch on that we'd be remiss to skip is
uh Han's discussion of Borden boredom
versus hyperactivity
um and the the quote quotation that I
remember him bringing up is animals
multitask or something like that and
that boredom is where
creativity self-reflection kind of the
values that
the philosophical values that we have
they come out of being bored thinking
about what could be and not using your
time to generate or create or produce or
commodify but rather just being bored
and one of Eric's favorite quotes come
out of Kim who comes out of here so I'm
not going to take it away from you you
can bring it up but the contrast of
hyperactivity as the hyper positivity
that eventually just drains your ability
to pay attention to things carefully and
what we might say is a phenomenological
sense of being aware of your
surroundings and then the application of
that of course to uh social media our
favorite topic I think this actually
applies to the bartop case though
because schopenhauer had a really great
argument in the world as well in
representation where he says many of the
philosophers hitherto have not really
analyzed the importance of boredom but
I'm going to Grant it substantial
ontological significance and he says the
reason that we should allocate so much
attention to boredom is boredom shows
you how life is not worth living by
itself because being bored is
essentially having nothing but life and
time available to you
and nothing more right and he says if
life was actually worth living for its
own sake we would never be bored because
we could be content with mere existence
but we're not there always has to be
something that fills us up uh or gives
us something to do you know Trump and
Howard has his own arguments about this
but it kind of reminded me of this
Bartleby uh example right because what
ends up happening with Barnaby at the
end is he strips away so much that
eventually at the end you have to
imagine that the kind of Passage he
takes into nothingness is a really bored
resigned one rather than some epic
gesture of defiance yeah it's almost
like he just finds everything so tedious
now that he's not going to bother with
anything any longer because what's the
[ __ ] point Heidegger says the mood of
boredom is like allowing the world to
retreat from you as if you you could
seize upon it but you kind of let it Let
It Go but we're I I set you up Eric for
your favorite quote maybe I'll lead into
it by saying I get I guess boredom today
in modern society is maybe the
equivalent of leisure in in ancient
Greek society right we just say we need
Leisure to have philosophy and today we
need boredom to tell stories but but the
problem is we don't want to be bored
anymore we can't handle it
our our threshold for boredom is so low
that we can't even watch old movies
anymore I mean like sure yeah like film
Buffs aside we can't even watch old
movies
especially not movies that exercise that
sort of Paul Schrader transcendental
style if you ever go to watch the tree
of life right like some people think the
tree of life is just the most boring
[ __ ] movie they've ever seen because
it's just slow Cinema it's got long
takes it's got deep shots deep focus
right so our threshold for boredom is
gone and our boredom is when we tell
stories this is this is Benny means
complaint is that we don't
like an event happens a big event
happens let's whatever 9 11. a big event
happens and we don't we can we don't we
can't blink but that there's a thousand
explanations thrown in our direction
right we're we're over stimulated and we
can't be bored but for Benjamin I mean
the big quote is boredom is the dream
bird that Hatches the Egg of experience
there it is and in another way boredom
is the time where we make up stories
about things and we pass on culture and
knowledge in a certain way that we don't
do anymore
yeah I I would actually give that a bit
of an adornian twist right because one
of the things that adorno and Port
Harbor Point out in all their work on
the culture industry and I've always
thought this was observant is that
precisely because we refuse to be bored
any longer we tend to engine to
hyper-real stimuli that are offered to
us by many of these different outlets
right whether we're talking about manic
uh pop culture uh or we're talking about
you know drugs and alcohol and so on and
so forth and I'm not here to disparage
all those since I think they have their
place right but they do insist that no
you know and a healthier society would
see boredom or Leisure Time as an
opportunity to actually reflect
critically on the the social conditions
in which we live and ask ourselves in
what sense they could be made better
right I don't want to get too much into
that but I think it's very true to this
benjaminian ethos right that rather than
approaching boredom productively right
uh we approach it as a problem that
almost has to be managed and solved
through consumption and through in this
case the culture industry right or even
even creatively approaching boredom
right like boredom is supposed to be
like a psychological canvas on which to
project our fantasies and our emotions
and our are sort of ways of life and and
try to put them in in a narrative form
that we can pass down right like
Benjamin was was on the radio a lot
telling stories back in the day there's
a book called radio Benjamin that has
transcripts of all the and he just sort
of tells children's stories and and
reads little poems and things like that
and it's awesome but we don't we don't
do that anymore we don't care for
stories anymore
and it's it's unfortunate and that it's
part of the burnout society and our our
tolerance in the face of
over stimulation information overload we
just no longer have any tolerance for
just sitting and being with ourselves
and being with our thoughts and being
with that sort of grand psychological
canvas that we might call boredom
yeah I mean I've referenced this book
before but I like it so much that it
deserves a reference again you know Neil
Postman points out that uh during the
1860s people who went to go listen to
Abe Lincoln uh and various pro-slavery
uh Defender speak we're willing to sit
down and listen to them talk for four
hours at a time including an
intermission right uh and one of the
points he asked is who do you think
would be willing to listen to a four
hour debate today even about an
extremely important topic right uh I
know a lot of people on Twitter are
complaining that the Trump Biden debate
was too long right even though it was
barely an hour right uh and most of the
things that we want have to be
compressed down to five ten minutes
Victor do you have any uh Reflections
before I move to my last musing
um
no I guess I'm just a little bored over
here right now well that's good
it's the nest what is it the Mythic egg
or net dream egg
dream egg of great yeah the the dream
bird that Hatches the Egg of experience
I'm trying to face my board and boredom
head-on all right so the very last
question that I have here is the
question of form
uh the form in which it's written which
I personally found frustrating uh
because
first of all as we mentioned it's only
60 Pages or so maybe 70.
um it's very pithy
and it almost is like
he writes every sentence almost so that
it could be a quotation
uh like a Twitter status almost that was
that was my impression of it so I found
I felt
you should tweet the book out line by
line
um I I found that anytime that I got
frustrated with a thesis
or an assertion they're never defended
and you don't have time to
you know go deeper into it and I am the
kind of person who kind of knows most of
what he's talking about too and I want
it more developed so I was wondering if
you think this is
uh an audience or for an academic
audience not for knock academic audience
if you if he believes that we're over
stimulated then why is he writing a book
that's
more or less a list of tweets
and he's 16 books in what like six years
or something like that I think it's
actually more than that but they are
very digestive very quick very short
books they're made so that you don't get
bored reading them
that is paradoxical didn't you say it
was made to be quoted and in terms of
being an entrepreneur right he's an
academic name doesn't really write
academic books I mean I shouldn't say
that I haven't read them all but most of
them are you know similar page length
they're kind of extended papers so I was
wondering you were calling it Theory
light Theory light which I like right
because you should be as an academic
writing stuff that inspires people to go
read more Theory and you should be
trying to get ideas out there rather
than
focusing on minutia but I guess I faced
or I got in the face
sort of the thing that I espouse and
hope for
um but then I even found myself saying
well I wish you would talk about this a
little more and I wish he would defend
this thesis of negativity versus
positivity so I wanted to uh go around
we'll start with Eric and just
comment on the comment on the Forum here
yeah the style is a very sort of pithy
aphoristic
concise
style look at first yeah it wasn't I'm
not used to reading this sort of stuff
because I'm trying to read for a
dissertation
and I'm I'm used to I'm used to heavily
footnoted and reference things and this
one's a little more sparse
but I think I I came to appreciate it
especially after I watched there's a
documentary out there about about Han as
well and he actually
narrates quite a bit of it and and after
I sort of watched it and
and looked at his sort of tarrying with
the with boredom and terrying with the
moments of silence and I sort of saw
that now in his writing style it's like
it's it's slow it's meant to make you
stop and think not run ahead and see
what's next and I don't know in a way it
reflects his points that he's trying to
make overall and I really liked again on
that idea of of being bored
he says like the the person who's bored
just gives in to the boredom and tries
to get away from it and doesn't realize
what it is that's making them bored but
the person who is
tolerant of boredom uh can spend a
little more time and figure out what it
is so if you're you're walking for
example and the one with the high
tolerance figures out it's it's walking
that makes them bored so they dance
and and he says dancing or gliding is an
entirely new form of motion it's not
running or jogging which is just walking
sped up it's a new form of motion this
is only human beings can dance that's
that's a whole sentence would you find
that in Duluth and gutari or or
Descartes only human beings Can Dance
full stop it is just it is uh only human
beings can dance it may be that boredom
seized him while walking so that after
and through this attack of boredom he
would make the step from walking to
dancing
so it's so it's kind of like this whole
book is a little bit like a little a
dance he's tarrying with the not with
the negative that's a giziakian thing
he's tearing with the positive but he's
he's dancing through it and he's trying
to uh encourage us to hop onto his
wavelength I think and I I I came to
appreciate it in in a strange way after
being a little resistant at first
yeah I mean I I would almost contrast it
with other big post-post modernist tomes
like Infinite Jest or anything by the
late Thomas pension which try to almost
respond to our condition the other way
by just presenting such a massive
information uh that you almost feel
overwhelmed by it and you are supposed
to feel like you're integrated into a
totalizing system that isn't going to
let you go and that you'll never fully
understand and you know those books
can't do that effectively uh but I the
way I saw this book was that it reminded
me a lot more something by Roland Barth
or Marshall mcluhan you know it's kind
of 60s ish works that were commenting on
similar problems in the culture uh in
that their aesthetic is designed to
express the
both Express and criticize the culture
uh that they're a part of right because
certainly is very cognizant of the fact
that this kind of pithy style appealing
to affect uh and Sensibility is deeply
reflective uh of the kind of society
that is criticizing right but on the
other hand it's almost like it's a
conception to that in an ironic sense an
acknowledgment of that if you're going
to try to change people's mind this is
now what you have to do
right and so it's going to become a
stylistic exercise in critiquing using
the ecstatic sensibilities of the
society at hand right and so I don't
know I thought it was creative that way
yeah in terms of entrepreneurialism the
the word that came to mind with this
book was slogeneering which is
exactly the opposite of what the content
is so maybe it was an ironic choice I
don't know anyway uh Victor
yeah I agree I mean I really liked what
Eric said I thought that that was well
put and uh I think that
it's true I mean the book did make me
uh I enjoyed it I mean I would
definitely recommend it to our lit to
our listeners it's since it's so short
it's it's and it's a pretty easy read
it's like a nice way it's a nice like
wetting your beak with some Theory but I
think there's there's some good ideas
here but I do think it also suffers from
the typical
like kind of critical like diagnostic of
society and like the malaise of society
kind of theory work that they all do
where they make these kind of broad
sweeping statements and and and maybe
more so in this book too because it is
shorter and it is pithy that as as pills
said right that there are certainly
claims that are made that you know from
my own you know uh in the process of
writing a dissertation like rigorous
like it's like okay well I'll get like I
want to know more about that claim a
little bit here and there but but it was
enjoyable would recommend it but yeah
just typical you know making broad
sweeping statements about society and
how it's making us sick and all that in
these really broad ways that that are
really affectively charged and do get
hit you in the gut and you're like hey
there's something to this but that also
makes me a bit suspicious of them while
I overall I agree with what Eric said I
do that there's the other side of me
that is like oh yeah it's like tugging
at me it's like making me be like yeah
like Society is this way and like we are
turning into this and I'm like but it's
very sweeping and yeah
all right so this was our first oh you
have a final thought Matt
no I just wanted to say that's
completely ripping off that like I I
feel it both ways about it as well
because I like academic argumentation uh
with their essays or book on the other
hand are you gonna sit there and tell
tsliator Emily Dickinson like well your
poems weren't actually strictly argument
and argued right you just kind of made
Brazen assertions about the society you
lived in yeah that's why we need a new
category for it Theory light was floated
exploratory Theory Theory crafting which
is what YouTube and podcasts are for
because you can you can put forward an
argument and you don't have to do the
work of Defending it which is excellent
for all Twitter Theory all academics
um so this is our first
book review
um so I think we should give it a a
rating out of four pills or so
because that would be encouraging the
entrepreneurial Society
well I'm gonna actually rate this
differently I would give it because I
had when I was actually doing academic
work I had what I would call my Sunday
books which are the books that you want
to read
for enjoyment but you're not allowed to
like cite in your dissertation so
they're less serious but more engaging
and as a Sunday book I would definitely
give this a four out of four pills
but as a as an academic book
it's it's hovering more around like I
don't know Neil Postman level where you
where it's you shouldn't take it to put
it into an academic argument as elitist
as it sounds that's just the fact of it
yeah I mean I think I would probably I
mean I think I would rate a book based
on what I take the book to be trying to
accomplish and how well it did that
so I think that this book for what it
was trying to do which is I think be
this kind of like Theory light like take
on society I'd probably give it like
three and a half pills out of four
a blue pink blue pink blue pink blue
whichever one is less reactionary yeah
I'm hesitant to quantify my uh my
appreciation of this book
um
at first it was probably like I mean at
first it was definitely like one but
that is true I had exactly the same
experience I hated it when I started I
was like this makes no sense but reading
back my notes I'm like this is of 70
pages
this is a really good 70 pages
yeah I thought that too it is Punchy it
hits with I mean I think in terms of
thinking about Foucault and discipline
society and Duluth and control Society I
think I will be thinking about burnout
society and I love the way that it's an
ongoing project too because he talks
about the transparency Society next and
he he kind of keeps building on this
same idea I love that I mean can I just
say too it's funny like like that's such
a good example of what I meant too when
I was saying you know this like Theory
tendency to make broad it's like to you
know this this fixation wanting to
define the age right like we're in this
age now and it's like so it's it's so uh
you know um all-encompassing and like
serious and it's like we're now in the
burnout society and we used to be in the
disciplinary Society but now we're in
the achievement society and it's like
okay
relax yeah I can see that too
I I liked it a lot more after I watched
that documentary about him too so and
I'd go out and I'd go find it is in
German you'll just have to watch it with
subtitles but
it helped me it definitely the visuals
and and and seeing him
walking around and interacting with
people and talking and the way he talks
to his colleagues and other people and
the shots like it just really helps I
still have that documentary open in a
tab on my uh on my Chrome I plan to
watch it soon
all right well thank you very much
everyone this was our first book review
if you if this is what we should be
doing with our Patron episodes let us
know
comments below but just don't make them
too long books because I have to reach
it for my dissertation I just don't have
time as long as there's as long as
they're Sunday books
we're down or articles whatever
that'd be fun articles would be fun yeah
it's our first try at this let us know
what you think thanks as always for
continuing to support us
uh we sound so much better this year
dudes like with the with the new mics
yeah it's good it's it's astronomically
better at least to my ears yeah well
you're the one editing them so you
listen to us probably the most of
anybody
that's true well some some of you are
more tiring than others some of you are
burning me out faster than others I
won't say who oh
all right see you guys
[Music]